So this book is important for, of course, a number of reasons. It's the first edition
of the publication of David Walker's Appeal, but it's also a copy owned by W.E.B. Du Bois,
who was the preeminent scholar
of the 20th century as it relates to
African American history and life. I would say the chances are great that he
had this both as a student when he was
at Harvard. But also in his own personal
library, of course, when he was teaching
at Atlanta University, and and throughout
his his life and career. And I would
argue that in his 1903 volumes The Souls
of Black Folk he's actually speaking to
David Walker. And there's a passage that
he is actually remembering Walker and
some of the other brave souls that
pushed back against slavery and
then into segregation, into Jim Crow.
Du Bois writes, and this is in The Souls of
Black Folk "Of Our Spiritual Strivings," he
says, The history of the American Negro
is a history of this strife, -- this longing
to attain self-conscious manhood, to
merge his double life into a better and
truer self. In this merging he wishes
neither of the older selves to be lost.
He would not Africanize America for
America has too much to teach the world
and Africa. He would not bleach his Negro soul in a flood of white Americanism for
he knows that Negro blood has a message for the world. He simply wishes to make
it possible for a man to be both a Negro
and an American without being cursed and
spit upon by his fellows, without having
the doors of opportunity closed roughly
in his face. And so while David Walker is
appealing to the enslaved to rise up
against their masters and those that
would keep them in bondage, Du Bois is
asking for acknowledgment of this--you
know, the the selves being both the Negro
and the American, what he's calling and
identifies as double consciousness.
But he also acknowledges the fact that there
are those who have attempted to bridge
this gap for generations that have failed,
because there's no dialogue.
There's no way to enter into the
conscience of these people,
that would keep people as chattels, that would oppress people.
The magnitude of this institution and what it's done to
these individuals in their spirit--it
wasn't just ignorance to the world, it was
just ignorance to the self. You know, you
believed that you were a beast.
You believed that you were not worthy of any
kind of compassion, human compassion if anything.
So, it is a series of essays that, really, I think, inspire revolution and the hearts of men.
But also it becomes--it's like a
foretelling of what was to come, in
terms of Nat Turner's rebellion and
eventually what the Civil War wrought. So, I mean, the books they work really well together,
because you get kind of an understanding of this pre-Civil War,
pre-abolitionist movement kind of time period, and abolitionism in terms of the
you know leading to the Civil War.
But you're getting these men who are
using their intellect to make an
argument against this institution that
made beasts of people, of human beings.
Some say, "made monsters of men."
You have to imagine, and it's hard to imagine, how
human beings can not only categorize
other human beings as less than human,
but really act out these really barbaric
kind of procedures or, you know, gestures towards.
I mean, it's interesting when you look
through some of the materials we have
in the archives, that you would have actual
slave documents, bills of sale, right.
So, human chattels. But then there are
also books. There are also accounts of how
these people were brutalized by the
slaveholders, by their overseers, by the
system in and of itself. And to create a
category in a society of civilization of,
you know, people so low that they
themselves don't know it and function at
a level so low that it is
horrendous to understand how you come
out of that. How does one survive that? Not
only physically, but mentally?
How do you imagine yourself in the future because
the only future you can imagine is
day to day, and not projected into the
next century, or the next decade, you know?
So to have the, really,
the audacity to write something such as this
in 1829, is to really feel, I guess,
a sense of being free. I'm free to say
what needs to be said because if death
is my destiny I will embrace it.
And I think he is challenging his brethren to understand that: this is no life.
The challenge is to rise up and to claim
your life and the lives of those yet born.
We also have to understand
that this book published in 1829--
Nat Turner's rebellion was in 1831, and there
are you know connections made to this
document inspiring this kind of--these
revolts. But the revolts were already
happening they were happening on
small-scale farms are happening in large
farms. But to have this published in 1829
and then to have Nat Turner's rebellion
it's really, you know, telling of
the tinderbox that was America,
and that this institution was bound to fail.
And then later on, of course, with the
Civil War, you know, you have
people like Frederick Douglas, who was
agitating for justice and trying to bring
the nation to understand its faults.
But of course you have half the
country's population in the South, that
believes that this War of Northern
Aggression is intended to change their
way of life. Disregarding the fact that
the argument eventually becomes about
the institution of slavery, and keeping
men and women in bondage.
It's an amazing history and amazing for a number of
reasons, in both, you know, infamous ways,
but also very important stories of, you
know, triumph and success and
perseverance. And I think in these
materials that we have, you know, all of
them together tell a story. Separately,
they're different kind of narratives, but
together they tell the story of a people
coming from, you know, a situation or
position in a community, or in a country
that disregarded them, but they saw their
own value. And in seeing their own value,
they allow themselves to be transformed
and continue to strive towards this
place that we're in today, I guess we can say.